bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france vous dénoncer des
conditions de travail à risque
l approche des fêtes de quoi s'agit-il
concrètement en fait le problème de
risque c'est que on craint des clubs
tard déjà dans un premier pas et dans un
deuxième temps c'est aussi que en fait
il ya des personnes extérieures on ne
sait pas s'il ya des cas de conduite
parce que surtout qu allah qui vient en
covoiturage donc la première attitude
elle est là et ensuite c'est le fait que
ben on constate que le semaine après
semaine on même voit jour après jour les
cas augmentent à pied sensiblement c'est
vrai que le cas d'amazon est quand même
particulier dans ce contexte aussi de
crise économique
c'est une entreprise qui prospère tout
cas la vente en ligne ça fonctionne en
perles de confinement là en fait que
reprochez vous concrètement au groupe
amazon france c'est de ne pas instaurer
les les gestes barrières nécessaires
pour justement protéger les salariés
en fait les gestes barrière je fais que
il ce 7e jose qui le font il essaie de
faire avec leur nom simplement c'est que
voilà fait qu on a le gros souci
particulier ses bas les intégrations
qu'ils arrivent et il ya aussi à notre
souci c'est pour les personnes qui sont
dites fragiles
donc on veut pas qu'ils aient un
accident grave dans l'entreprise c'est
surtout sa 65e leurs confrontations
notre grande et une des revendications
qu'on a demandé à la direction et que et
personne ne puisse puisse arrêter chez
eux avec un maintien de salaire à 100 %
afin qu'ils soient en sécurité
il est quelles réponses avez vous obtenu
moyens concrets pour environ 65 cas
positifs au coc u19 ont été recensés la
semaine dernière sur les sites français
d'amazon est ce que selon vous c'est
vraiment
due aux conditions de travail que vous
dénoncez est difficile à dire parce que
en fait et il ya de tout et de tout
faire un tout ça peut être les
conditions de travail comme ça peut être
aussi les intégrations parce que vous
savez vous savez plus en mai des
personnes et plus les cas de contact
peuvent augmenter et être qui arrive
actuellement
vous dites que vous n'avez rien obtenu
il ya une absence de dialogue au sein
d'entreprises
en fait nous parce qu'il ya un dicton
qui était faite au sujet de la prime d
exceptionnelle de 1000 euros implique
que les deux euros de l'heure qui nous
ont été clairement refusé à porto pour
preuve que la réunion a tourné très
court alors quelles sont les actions
maintenant que vous comptez mener
justement pour faire face aux conditions
de travail compliquées que vous dénoncez
bas actuellement bas on a actuellement
on essaie de renégocier on va pas lâcher
le morceau sur ce sujet là parce que
faut pas oublier que tous les salariés
sont confrontés les notes qui est le
virus et donc voilà après les autres
d'action s'en verra en fonction de ce
que la direction va va décider parce que
parfois ils ont peut-être non mais c'est
pas un nom définitif on va voir s'ils
vont quand même continuer à négocier sur
ce sujet va juste cette dernière
question puisque on approche des fêtes
ça veut dire pour amazon france on peut
l'imaginer en tout cas que la main
d'oeuvre ben c'est quand même important
ou ce que vous demandez en tout cas la
direction
c'est peut-être vous ne vous opposez pas
une main d'oeuvre supplémentaire mais
être plus de
2 améliorer les conditions d'intégration
c'est ça et ouais il y avait remporté il
ya pas utile à une reconnaissance des
salariés parce que vous oubliez que tous
les salariés sont confrontés face à
cette menace
donc en plus comme amazon fait quand
même des bénéfices et que c'est
important et ils disent pas le contraire
parce que monsieur duval lors d'une
interview il avait 10 40 qu'il y avait
une augmentation entre 40 et 50%
donc c'est pas à négliger donc sur ce
sur ce principe
je trouve qu'il faut que la direction
soit reconnaissante au près de sept
salariés en faisant une prime
exceptionnelle et bien sûr des 2 euros
et 2 euros de l'heure comme c'est prévu
ce qui est tout à fait merci beaucoup à
vous emilien williate d'avoir répondu à
nos questions directes sur arte france
je rappelle que vous êtes les délégués
cgt donc sur le site amazon de l'oim
planque
merci à vous